[Musique]
pierre-emmanuel valentin bonjour bonjour
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle think ur
view on aurait voulu avoir quelques
détails sur votre business qu'est ce que
vous faites dans la vie je suis
président du directoire de la nef c'est
quoi la nef à c'est toute une histoire
d'abord la nef on vous écoute
aujourd'hui c'est un établissement de
crédit spécialisés c'est l'agrément que
nous avons de la part des autorités
bancaires en france foulée du conte
premiers agréments remonte à 1988 et
puis je viens d'être étendu en 2015 pour
élargir leurs activités la démarche
avait été entreprise par qui l'histoire
de la nef c'est d'abord un groupe de
gens qui constitue une association qui
s'appelle la nouvelle économie
fraternelle on est dans les années
soixante dix
et ce groupe de gens cherchent à
faciliter l'accès au financement pour
des projets qu'on qualifie maintenant
d'alternative je ne sais pas si le mot
existait à l'époque des projets dans le
domaine de l'agriculture dans le domaine
de la pédagogie dans le domaine des
médecines douces et puis cette cette
aventure militante elle s'ancre dans une
structure financière en 1988 pour lui
donner plus d'ampleur cette structure
financière l'obtient un agrément de la
part de la banque de france
avec le soutien du crédit coopératif qui
d'emblée le parrain puisque il donne à
la banque de france a garanti si jamais
la nef se trouve en difficulté
financière par exemple vis-à-vis de ses
déposants et bien c'est le crédit
coopératif qui garantit notre
solvabilité
notre liquidité
nous sommes constitués dès l'origine en
coopérative
avec un directoire et un conseil de
surveillance et puis la chique et tout
directoire mais avant ça
j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde sur le mou
fraternelle
vous entendez fraternelle par liberté
égalité fraternité ou fraternelle
maçonnique
écoutez je ne sais pas très bien ce que
veut dire le fraternel maçonnique mais
on va dire que je les imagine est donc
vraisemblable en plus tôt dans une
acception comparables la nef elle
s'ancre vraiment dans la grande
tradition humaniste donc j'imagine que
se doivent d'être proche de la tradition
vous évoquez donc pour nous la
fraternité c'est
la capacité de l'homme à voir au-delà de
lui-même et en particulier dans sa
relation avec l'argent pour construire à
partir de cet argent une une relation
bienveillante une relation non violente
une relation
entrepreneuriale constructive
ça va avec une vision d'homme qu'on va
qualifier de transcendance même si ce
mot peut faire feu peut poser question
mais c'est bien notre ca tout ce qui est
une vision d'ordre qui est à l'origine
de cette démarche de la nef la
transcendance pourquoi ça pose la
question parce que on est dans un monde
où tout ce qui est de l'ordre de
d'une dimension
supra matériel pose problème nous nous
revendiquons une ouverture une dimension
spirituelle transcendante même si nous
sommes ancrés dans le réel nous exerçons
un métier de banque et ce métier de
banque
vous êtes le commerce à partir de là
j'ai comme le vatican est une banque
religieuse non assurément non on est
dans une banque totalement ouverte à
toutes les traditions vous vous trouvez
dans les projets que nous finançons des
projets portés probablement par des
associations religieuses mais nous
sommes nous à la recherche de tout ce
qui va apporter une valeur ajoutée qu'on
appelle sociale culturelle
environnementale
territoriales tout ce qui peut concourir
on appelle ça dans notre jargon à une
transition vers un monde plus
respectueux de l'homme et de la planète
oui pour résumer c'est notre fil
conducteur vous n'êtes pas franc maçon
non je ne suis pas franc maçon seul un
fret autorisées à se découvrir ça je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas pour moi ça
reste un monde un peu mystérieux mais je
ne je n'ai jamais fréquenté ce que vous
connaissez un monsieur qui s'appelle
steiner oui bien sûr puisque cette
philosophie de rudolf steiner fait
partie de nos racines nous avons
d'autres mais ça fait partie de nos
racines et certains des militants
originel
de l'association la nef
même si je ne les ai pas côtoyer compte
tenu de mon jeune âge mais il m'a été
raconté qu'il faisait partie
effectivement
d'associations proches de la pensée de
rudolf steiner
et pour vous donner un exemple
très très concret cette pensée de rudolf
steiner a notamment inspiré le mouvement
agricole s'appelle la biodynamie qui est
une forme de lait pierre rabhi c'est un
non non bien avant pierre rabhi un
la biodynamie est assez ancienne pierre
aby c'est plutôt l'agrobiologie mais les
deux démarches sont très proches celle
s'interpénètrent on est bien dans la
même mouvance d'une culture agricoles
respectueuses de l'ensemble de son
environnement et qui est au coeur
maintenant de la démarche bio bien connu
et qui prend de plus d'eau plus de place
dans la production agricole française
ça vous pose un problème que vos racines
aux fondations touche à la philosophie
de steiner
c'est une des racines nous avons
d'autres racines à au départ 100 % du
board était entreposée au foehn ont
coûté au moment qui vous a rapporté ça
d'ailleurs eh bien c'est la chaîne des
fondateurs puisque les les fondateurs de
l'association se sont retrouvés à la
base de la fondation de la société
financière en 1988 et donc des écrits
ont été posées sur la vision des
fondateurs de la nef dans la relation
avec l'argent donc moi ça ne peut pas se
pose pas problème que l'établissement
qui m'emploie et auxquels je consacre
toute mon énergie et des racines ce qui
m'importe c'est la compréhension que
maintenant tout le monde tous les
acteurs tout est partie prenante de la
neige aujourd'hui on de ses racines et
ses racines elles sont laissons elles
sont peut-être un peu gangrène est quand
même dans steiner vous connaissez son
idéologie côté je n'ai pas je ne suis
pas un spécialiste
de la pensée de rudolf steiner g non
plus
on a fait trois heures d'internet j'ai
regardé
élu certain nombre de ses propos
concernant
je dirais la la médecine concernant les
du queyras non ça je n'ai pas côtoyer ce
c'est une partie très croustillantes
quand même je n'en doute pas miss quand
les sens du terme quand je parlais tout
à l'heure de racines ça ne fait pas
partie des racines qui nous ont inspiré
la nef avec ce mot fraternelle elle pose
clairement en
pierres angulaires de sa démarche une
ouverture à toutes les traditions ou une
ouverture à toutes les pensées quelle
qu'elle soit nous sommes
fondamentalement laïque et nous sommes
vraiment avec chevillée au corps un
esprit de non violence de fraternité de
bienveillance vous trouver la trace de
ses mots dans les chartes qui nous
gouvernent actuellement ce que vous
pouvez comprendre que sur internet
certains vous reprochent d'être un peu
comme là je sais pas s'il parle elle va
être bon si la bonne mais on vous
reproche d'être un petit peu la
scientologie de la banque
écoutez moi je suis respectueux de
toutes les pensées y compris les pensées
critiques silence respectueux et de la
scientologie c'est une
c'est une secte en france c'est une
secte mais je n'ai je ne les connais pas
je ne suis donc pas spécialement
respectueux de la scientologie ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement
nous avons figuré comme un certain
nombre d'institutions
dans un rapport parlementaire de la fin
des années 90 c'est la miviludes dans
l'ancienne division de ses sa non je
crois que c'était la miviludes à
l'époque
depuis nous je crois que mes
prédécesseurs ont fait un une instance
judiciaire donc en diffamation le nom de
la nef a été retiré de ses listes
sectaire et pour ma part qu'il années 50
et moi la mémoire que j'en ai de ce
rapport parlementaire je dirais la fin
des années 90
et la décision de justice à laquelle je
fais référence ses débuts des années
2000 voilà à peu près les dates
auxquelles on se réfère moi quand je
suis arrivé dans l'environnement nef
après c'est dans le crédit mutualistes
c'est ça la banque mutualiste moi j'ai
fait toute ma carrière dans des banques
mutualistes et coopératives
bon écoute et on va passer à autre chose
la nef maintenant elle pèse combien un
bilan de 450 millions d'euros un capital
de 40 millions d'euros et derrière ce
capital vous avez 38000 société 40
millions d'euros vous êtes sur ses
pattes 39e le oui c'est 39 950
je vous félicite delà
de la force de vos références
expliquez moi un petit peu votre coeur
de business maintenant si je viens chez
vous je vais ouvrir un compte en banque
je trouverai un compte courant pas un
compte courant qu'est-ce que je peux
faire chez vous imaginez vous j'ai cent
mille euros a placé et bien notre coeur
de business comme vous dites c'est de
proposer aux épargnants
de donner un sens à leur argent et de
leur donner une visibilité sur
l'utilisation que nous allons en faire
pour financer des projets comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure à valeur
ajoutée sociale environnementale
culturelle donc et des projets qui sont
dans dans cette dynamique à côté de
cette transparence ce que nous mettons
sur la table c'est un
j'allais dire une garantie garantie sans
rien du tout un prêt supposer de
comportement éthique avec cet argent
c'est quoi les tic il ya l'éthique c'est
la vision propre que nous emportons n'ya
pas d'éthique absolue nous le sens que
nous donnons à notre éthique et bien
c'est en tant que banque bien sûr une
éthique ça n'a de sens que par rapport à
l'endroit où on se pose sur le monde
mais nous nous posons sur le monde en
tant que banque et le sens que nous
donnons à notre éthique c'est c'est
notre vision de l'argent donc c'est un
comportement non spéculatif
c'est un comportement nous ne faisons
pas de l'argent un outil d'appropriation
d'accumulation
c'est un comportement marquée par
l'absence de rémunération variable une
échelle de salaires réduite comme vont
toucher mais donc moi mons mon salaire
brut mensuel est de 7000 euros ce qui
nous fait 5000
ce qui doit faire cinq dans vous comptez
certainement 23 24 % de prélèvements
donc
donc n'être dans l'est dans les 6000
6500 doigt dedans c'est dans ces eaux là
revoilà non c'est à 5005 par le plus
haut salaire chez vous c'est combien
c'est le mien donc 7000 euros brut par
mois est juste en dessous c'est combien
le deuxième salaire nous sommes trop
directoire mon monde collègues
le mieux payé derrière moi doit être à
6005 est le plus bas 1800 je parle
toujours en brut mensuels pour 1800
auront fait quoi chez vous eh bien on
est on est gestionnaire c'est à dire que
soit vous êtes dans un
dans un service pour traiter des
opérations bancaires
soit vous êtes dans une délégation
commerciale
pour être en
assistance commerciale et administrative
gagné combien banques mutualistes je
gagne plus d'argent combien quand
j'étais à la directeur général de la
banque fédérale mutualiste je gagnais
environ 210 euros par an bruts net brut
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé de changer
écoutez je suis à un âge où
opposons se pose pas mal de questions
quel âge j'ai 62 ans donc j'ai décidé de
changer
bien j'en avais j'en avais deux ou trois
de moins et donc
quand on a passé toute sa vie
professionnelle dans le monde bancaire
en on additionne les questions le genre
de questions quel sens à tout ça en quoi
la finance peut être un outil de
construction du monde et non pas un
outil de destruction quoi ça peut être
un outil de responsabilisation d'hommes
et et non pas
d'avilissement en quoi ça peut être un
outil de financement de l'économie et
non pas
de désagrégation des sociétés dans
lesquelles nous sommes et donc j'étais
déjà au conseil de surveillance à titre
totalement bénévole de la nef depuis
2004 et il y avait quelque chose de
logique au moment où une
une porte professionnel s'est ouverte
quand je dis porte professionnel ouvert
ça veut dire que ma mission antérieur
arrivé à sa fin et donc il y avait un
besoin au niveau de la nef c'est sorte
de logique d'évidence pour moi aller à
venir finir marc carrière dans cette
coopérative
vous connaissez bernard esambert
côté c'est un an que j'ai croisés je ne
peux pas vous dire spontanément
quel est le
quelles sont les fonctions de bernard
isambert mais c'est un an que j'ai
certainement croiser dans mon parcours
si mes souvenirs sont bons il doit être
président d'honneur de l'école
polytechnique c'est un ancien de la
grande banque
rothschild si mes souvenirs sont bons
mais je dois m'en accommode vérifier et
qui a été conseiller de pompidou en ce
moment il est en train de créer un
conclave
pour la moralisation du capitalisme
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce sujet là
la moralisation du capitalisme et je
vais vous poser une autre question qui
une question qui risque d'être posée
dans pas très longtemps avec le dalaï
lama la responsabilité universelle
écoutez la moralisation du capitalisme
nous ne pouvons qu'être favorable la
démarche de la nef c'est de nous donner
des leçons de morale à personne nous
notre moral nous cherchons à la
mettre en oeuvre la personnifier par
notre façon d'être mais si des
mouvements se forment en particulier
initié par des professionnels de la
finance et du capitalisme en vue de
moraliser
les pratiques
de cette
cette forme d'être en société nous ne
pouvons que nous en réjouir nous mêmes
n'avons aucune prétention isolationniste
nous sommes en connexion avec la vraie
vie donc nous sommes en connexion avec
la façon d'exercer le métier de la
banque tels qu'il s'exerce aujourd'hui
nous sommes en connexion avec les
marchés avec le capitalisme nous n'avons
beaucoup de
nous perdre non seulement beaucoup de
respect mais nous font partie de nos
gènes les tout ce qui peut être de leur
démarche entrepreneuriale
donc on s'en réjouit alors pour pour
pour ce qui concerne
je dirais le sens que ça peut que ça
peut prendre pour nous
et
là votre allusion
donc au bien universel c'est cela la
responsabilité universelle on non nous
endossons totalement ce type de démarche
long mais d'autres mots
et nous aimons bien mettre le mot de
biens communs dans ce débat
pour nous il est très important que les
projets économiques
financiers entrepreneuriaux knu auquel
nous
nous prêtons est très important que nous
on y trouve cet exemple commander des
petites traces de biens communs les
l'exemple de ce que nous finançons va
prendre d'abord tout ce qui est dehors
de la filière bio
et donc nous ne nous voyons des des
résonances dans tous les entrepreneurs
qui s'inscrivent dans cette filière bio
nous voyons des résonances avec cette
approche de bien commun
au sens de respect de sens de respect de
la planète et the gun
non non moi je suis très fier car
personnellement
j'adore j'adore une entrecôte
mais je ne suis pas végal mais
effectivement dans les sociétaires nef
où vous devez certainement trouvé
alors vous êtes nil 2 janvier 1955 vous
avez été grand patron d'une banque nos
grands patrons de quoi pour toi moi je
n'ai les 200 cas de son cabinet dirigé
que des petites banques d'accord 200 cas
par an on va dire que sincère
confortable actuellement vous êtes
positionnés sur quoi votre épargne les
positionner sur quoi il est à la nef
vous avez transférer tout votre épargne
à la nef vous financé par vous même des
projets à travers la nef vous êtes
toujours dans vos anciennes banques vous
avez mis vos actifs dans différentes
banques vous êtes positionnés en euro
dollar en or en dollars qui est un cas
personnel oui
écoutez à titre personnel il y aura le
monde vous avez passé vos billes ou a
résumé un trivial personnel
mon patrimoine familial et immobilier et
donc je des france en belgique en vous
rendant en france donc je détiens ma
résidence principale à montreuil avec
mon épouse
est toujours avec avec elle nous
détenons deux appartements parisiens
dans le 11e arrondissement du liquide un
peu
quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros en
livrets bancaires et puis ce qu'on
appelle un perco c'est à dire un plan
d'épargne-retraite
qui est
donc lancé un coin
qui est sur des
déplacements
pour partie obligataire pour partie
actions géré par
la filiale d' épargne salariale de la
société générale vous avez confiance
dans la société générale sa capacité à
encaisser un choc financier oui c est ce
que ces fonds souverains sont
suffisamment importants par rapport au
protocole de gaulle 4 alors ça je suis
incapable de vous répondre ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai côtoyés et
associés trompe pas
c'est que j'ai côtoyés à société
générale
lorsque j'ai dirigé la bfm donc pendant
12 ans c'était notre autre partenaire
commercial puisque c'était par le biais
de la société générale et de son réseau
qui était diffusée les offres bancaires
de ce qui était à l'époque la banque
fédérale mutualiste maintenant devenue
la banque française mutualiste et moi
j'ai vu c'est pas une question de
confiance j'ai vu les
interlocuteurs société générale oeuvre
j'ai travaillé avec eux et j'ai un
respect professionnel pour
les personnes de la société générale
avec lesquels j'ai travaillé vous avez
des restes du respect pour des banques
qui peut financer des états totalitaires
prédateurs des actions contre
l'environnement par exemple via des
banques je ne citerai pas de nom
aujourd'hui son avocat n'est pas encore
prévenu et des bancs qui financerait des
mines de cuivre qui dégueulasse ray
l'argentine où des forages un peu cracra
l'éthique quand même dans la banque a
coûté à titre personnel je regrette très
vivement que mes confrères finances ce
type d'activité et c'est vrai mais vous
êtes au courant quand même que ça existe
je travaille dans le secteur bancaire
depuis près de 40 ans donc je j'ai une
connaissance qu'on peut qualifier
d'assez intime avec ce qui s'y passe
dans ce secteur bancaire y compris
ses turpitudes
donc je sais parfaitement quel déviance
on peut y trouver je sais parfaitement
quel écart de comportement une certaine
vision de l'argent peut amener donc je
regrette profondément ces déviations de
du métier que j'exerce
donc je n'ai au fuse à sion ou déviance
les deux à la fois si vous voulez parce
que il ya ce qui est de leurs de
l'institution et puis à ce qui est de
leur ressort des hommes qui la
constituent
dans certaines situations les deux se
renforce mais je sais aussi combien d
des personnes des professionnels de la
banque parfaitement
ancrée dans des convictions honnêtes
peuvent se laisser
circonscrire se laisser emporter pour
vous au delà de là où ils devraient
aller fourvoyé fourvoyé oui tout à fait
mais c'est une ça peut être une pente
savonneuse
ça peut être parfois des
circonstances de contrainte ou de
petites lâchetés une petite lâcheté plus
on a mené une autre légende urbaine qui
dit que tous les banquiers prennent de
la cocaïne peugeot a pris de la cocaïne
tu es n'ont peut-être d'ailleurs parfois
vous savez dans certains moments de
difficulté un être dirigeant
d'entreprise c'est pas toujours très
facile
je regrette effectivement que ma seule
turpitudes soit un verre d'alcool ici ou
là
je je ne dirais pas qu'il ya une petite
fille mais de temps en temps mais
peut-être fait un peu de bien quel type
de fumée de voir j'aurais peut-être
commencer par justin joue à écouter je
ne sais pas si s'il existe du cannabis
certifiés bio c'est probablement un
marché qui serait assez porteur alors
est ce que nous finançons serions une
culture de cannabis bio
écoutez chalet vous posez la question
dans mon élément j'aurais plutôt
tendance à regarder à porter un regard
amical sur un projet comme ça mais je
pense que notre directeur de la
conformité il trouverait à redire en
l'état actuel de la législation bon on
passera peut-être vous voir après si la
législation évolue et je voudrais on
voudrait avoir
votre perception
des marchés financiers au jour
d'aujourd'hui
cette cavalerie financière par les
banques centrales
et je voudrais avoir aussi votre
perception concernant hayek
vous écoute oui écoutez ma perception
par rapport à aujourd'hui aux
politiques menées par
les banques centrales
nous au niveau de la nef
on n'est pas je vous parlais ensuite de
ma réaction personnelle mais d'abord
vous dire quelle position nous au niveau
de la nef nous avons par rapport à cette
situation et par rapport aux politiques
macroéconomiques qui sont conduites nous
on se sent à côté de cette dynamique à
notre
notre relation aux marchés c'est une
relation de coexistence mais tout
l'esprit de la nef c'est de construire
sa propre logique de marché l'esprit de
la nef c'est d'être autonome dans son
accès à l'épargné qu'elle utilise dans
son accès à l'argent qu'elle utilise
donc nous nous souhaitons et on peut
dire que nous nous sommes aujourd'hui
entièrement dépendants de nos clients
est exclusivement de nos clients pour
accéder à la ressource que nous
réutilisons crédit est rentable non nous
ne sommes
présentement pas rentable et depuis deux
ans nous perdons de l'argent c'est sûr
qu'on payons des gens c'est nioro
alors ce sera me faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'honneur et l'importance de penser que
ce sont mes émoluments qui génère des
pertes pour la pub gratuite non mais je
vous en prie a jugé le ch et le cuir
épais et très sincèrement j'aime bien
être un peu chatouiller fallait pas me
dire ça vous a déçu du voyage vient
écouter que le que le voyage continue
mais pour reprendre le fil de mon propos
notre autre rail notre ligne de conduite
voyez notre arrêt voyez-vous m'emporter
vous me ramener sur l'accord sur la
trace mais notre
notre logique est bien de construire une
forme d'écosystèmes indépendant des
marchés même si en tant que banque ne
pouvons pas prétendre que nous sommes
étanche par rapport au marché quoi qu'il
en soit la vision que moi à titre
personnel je porte sur la politique de
la banque centrale européenne au risque
de vous surprendre est plutôt positive
moi je quelle raison écoutez j'essaye de
juger un arbre par ses fruits sains et
la vision que je peux avoir c'est que la
politique centrale la politique de la
banque centrale européenne a plutôt des
conséquences macroéconomiques positives
sur ce qu'on pourrait qualifier la
marche de l'économie en général
et les critiques que je pourrais porter
sur la politique économique ne sont pas
à ce niveau là
c'est à dire que pour vous fait que les
banques centrales se transforme en bad
bank ça vous pose pas de problème à
écouter derrière ces bad bank qui a eu
effectivement expliquez vous ce que
c'est une bonne bande à une bad bank est
une banque à l'inter de laquelle vous
vous trouvez des crédits que les clients
ne peuvent pas rembourser alors le
vraiment c'est des crédits pourris des
crédits pourris des job boards savez
comptablement on appelle on appelle ça
dans un bilan bancaires des créances
compromises ça veut dire quoi douteuse
est compromise ac c'est le terme
comptable des princes dutronc ce pas mal
mais si vous voulez que la banque
centrale européenne reprenne à son
compte
des crédits pourris comme vous le dites
que je dise la réalité c'est la réalité
de la part de banques qui ont
engrangé dans un
peut-être une propension exagéré a dit
comment proportions exagérées andy sugar
v oui mais derrière ça vous avez des
banques qui ont financé aussi des
crédits à l'économie même si ces crédits
n'ont pas donné lieu à remboursement
effet de levier de la deutsche bank
c'est combien alors c'est gigantesque
jeu
je peux pas vous le dire de mémoire mais
c'est vrai que la deutsche bank est un
magnifique exemple des déviances ou des
gigantesques c'est un ordre de grandeur
combien fourchette
ats que ce que je sais c'est que le
si on compare la nef et la deutsche bank
si vous comparez
d'un côté le rappeur semble donc leur
apport de capital entre la nef et la
deutsch bank et de l'autre côté le
rapport de bilan de la nef et des deux
banques
si je ne peux pas vous donner les
chiffres exacts mais si on prenait pour
hypothèse que le rapport entre le
capital de la nef et d'un document qui
était de 1 à 100 le rapport de bilan
serait de l'ordre de 1 à 1000 donc avec
la avec le même capital on peut dire que
la la deutsche bank qui a effectivement
joué de l'effet de levier mais surtout
ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que
c'est ce rôle de la banque centrale
européenne essayer de remettre un peu
d'ordre dans ses déviances bancaire au
sauve-qui-peut n'est pas jugé sévèrement
de la place qui est la mienne par contre
ce que je
regrette davantage c'est la vision que
la banque centrale européenne a
dans sa façon d'approcher la supervision
bancaire c'est à dire le financement
réel non
si vous voulez le raid sans regarder non
c'est pas ça que je veux dire le
thermomètre principal qui est utilisé
par
la banque centrale européenne et
l'ensemble des autorités bancaires
européennes pour superviser pour à
réguler le système bancaire ça s'appelle
le ratio de solvabilité c'est quoi le
ratio de solvabilité c'est une bête
fraction vous avez au numérateur les
fonds propres sur le capital et les
réserves et puis vous avez au au
dénominateur les risques c'est-à-dire
les crédits et la proche politique de la
banque centrale est une approche neutre
c'est-à-dire que la banque centrale au
delà de du réglage du thermomètre sera
le 10 le ratio doit être de temps mais
elle dit peu m'importe je simplifie mais
globalement c'est ce qu'elle dit peu
m'importe qui est financée ainsi au
dénominateur dans les risques de crédit
qui sont à couvrir par le numérateur le
capital collectées auprès des
actionnaires et des des coopérateurs
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de banques qui
sont coopérative peu m'importe que vous
faite de cet argent que vous financiers
comme on le disait tout à l'heure
éventuellement delà du trafic de drogue
ou que vous financier des armes n'ont
pas eu trafic de drogue de la
consommation et que vois je m'égare
que vous financier du trafic d'armes que
vous financier de la pornographie des
activités mafieuses ou peut-être des des
besoins du vatican pour aller au summum
de la vertu et bien peu ma porte est
donc je regrette que
les autres dieux
disons que ma croyance personnelle a pas
beaucoup d'importance mais on va y
revenir je fais comme si c'est à dire
vous croyez une force supérieure oui je
crois une force supérieure vient à
minima rythme et un ami imaginaire
un ami imaginaire
écoutez l'a emporté sur comme ça en
spontané peut-être sur des terrains que
j'avais pas imaginer on va dire mon ange
gardien oui je pense qu'il ya une force
supérieure qu'on lui mette ou non le nom
de dieu sur
dessus ne paraît pas forcément très
important c'est pourtant pour rentrer à
la nef d'avoir des croyances non non
mais quand même vous vous dire que ma
tradition personnel est une tradition
catholique donc j'ai les bonnes
références catholique je suis perméable
aux enseignements de l'évangile
chrétiens
continuez votre raisonnement concernant
les vents de 100 trains et donc ce que
je regrette c'est que les autorités
politiques ne se soit pas saisie de ce
fameux dénominateur du ratio de
solvabilité parce que et là je reprends
la casquette nef de notre point de vue
il n'est pas indifférent de savoir ce
qu'on finance et financer une activité à
et bien pour le bien-être sociétal c'est
pas la même chose que de financer
l'activité b et donc il nous semble
qu'une démarche politique élémentaire
pourrait consister à se rapprocher des
autorités de la banque centrale
européenne pour leur dire bien nous
politique nous avons une pensée à
formuler sur la façon dont on calcule ce
dénominateur et sur les pourcentages de
pondération qu on pourrait appliquer à
différentes natures de crédit et donc
considérer qu'il ya des natures de
crédit qui sont politiquement plus
désirable que d'autres plus soutenable
que d'autres
jugent de st comment qu'ils jugent 206
qui se concertent aujourd'hui personne
puisque il a été posé en principe
fondateur de la banque centrale
européenne qu'elle était autonome par
rapport au pouvoir politique et donc
nous nous
où ça je vais peut-être dire jeu parce
que là ce serait beaucoup faire beaucoup
parler mais mes collègues et et les
instances qui m'entourent pour employer
le nous mais je dirais qu'à titre
personnel je je considère qu'il est il
aurait été souhaitable de limiter la
zone d'autonomie d'indépendance de la
banque centrale européenne à son
activité de régulation de l'inflation et
que pour ce qui concerne la régulation
du secteur bancaire on puisse créer un
lien avec le politique pour que cette
ces décisions relatives à la pondération
des différents crédits qui rentrent dans
ce dénominateur relève de la décision
politique qu'est ce que vous pensez du
fonds de garantie des dépôts bancaires
français bien écouter gens pensent du
bien j'en pense du bien parce que
préparez votre cure parce que ça m'a
piqué enfin gens pensent du bien sur le
principe je crois que il est très
important de pouvoir offrir une sécurité
aux déposants on a vu à travers
différents épisodes de crise
au cours des temps passés qu'il y avait
des effets de contagion plus vous
enterrer ou laissez moi m'enterrer qui
avaient des effets de court je me
rendais terrerait peut-être avec votre
aide tout à l'heure j'ai passé de très
important
d'induire de la sécurité au niveau du
déposant pour essayer de couper court
aux effets de panique aux effets de
contagion et donc je crois qu'un système
de garantie mutualisé entre les banques
sur les dépôts de leurs clients et sain
dans une économie ouverte comme la nôtre
quelle est la taille bon allez on
commence la réchauffe quelle est la
taille du fonds de garantie décès
volontaire en france s est taillé
minimes g quoi minimes bah écoutez je
peux pas vous dire de chiffres précis ce
que je peux dire c'est que ce fonds de
garantie de doit couvrir comme ça un
ordre de grandeur que quelques pourcents
quelques petits pour s'entasser combien
par contré par l'établissement et elle a
la garantie doit être de leurs deux cent
mille euros par 110 jeu si mes souvenirs
sont bons 72 72 mille euros mais bon qui
par un
combo par an et par client par client
oui et ça fait beaucoup pas beaucoup si
on se prend un petit un petit choc sur
les banques votre avis est-ce que c'est
suffisamment dimensionné pour encaisser
un choc alors le fonds de garantie
si vous le limiter aux sommes qui sont
déposées dans ses caisses aujourd'hui
serait dans la capacité de faire face à
un choc massif c'est un choc massif d'un
choc massif c'est d'écouter au lieu de
faire chuter liman brothers vous fait
chuter aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas vous fait chuter les
grandes banques américaines
vous fait chuter les plus grandes
banques mondiales et on fait comment
pour faire chuter les plus grandes
banques mondiales
écoutez on laisse penser qu'elles ne
pourront pas honorer leurs échéances du
lendemain
mais pour en revenir à cette idée de
mutualisation
des risques à l'inter du système
bancaire je pense que c'est ça kuhn
une forme de garantie solidaire relie
les banques entre elles gérées par
l'état et cette forme de garanties
mutuelles de mon point de vue a plutôt
des effets vertueux que des effets
vicieux si vous pensez du glass steagall
act
coûtait pas grand chose un jeu je ne
prétends pas être à
un théoricien de la finance
internationale au niveau de la formation
des banques de faire de mon parcours je
suis assez franco français maintenant je
vais quand même tenté de répondre sur le
se glace steagall act
il ya eu des vélleités en france pour
essayer d'en faire une transposition ou
tout au moins en europe vérité qui n'ont
pas abouti pour la séparation des
banques d'affaires et et des banques de
détail
écoutez
sur le plan du principe moi j'y suis
plutôt favorable je ne suis pas persuadé
que ce soit le bon endroit pour pour
porter le faire si l'on se souvient
cette volonté de moralisation du métier
de la banque et de l' usage de l'argent
je suis pas persuadé que ce soit
l'endroit névralgique où il faille
porter l'effort pour vous je pense qu'on
peut être aussi véreux
dans le métier de banque de détail que
dans le métier de la banque d'affaires
pense que la fondamentale mans la
question n'est pas là de toute façon un
moment ou un autre l'épargné accumulée
par la banque de détail
peut toujours trouver le moyen de se
recycler dans les métiers de la banque
d'affaires à travers les financements de
marché
dont mon mon sentiment
serait qu' il faudrait mieux aborder
cette
volonté de moralisation et de vertu et
de remise de la banque au service de
l'économie par d'autres biais vous
emprunter auprès de la bce
nous n'empruntons pas auprès de la bce
nous sommes nous dans une
démarche que j'avais qualifié tout à
l'heure d'écosystèmes où nous utilisons
pour employer ce mot bancaire auprès de
nos propres clients
bon
qu'est ce que je vais vous poser comme
question
je réfléchis le shadow banking ça vous
fait penser à quoi le shadow banking ça
me fait d'abord penser au fameux au
fameux iphone
et donc là je pense qu'on aurait un
angle d'attac
beaucoup plus intéressant un cartel
faire pour porter le faire oui oui quand
quand je vois la
l'enrichissement absolument
débile c'est même pas délirant c'est de
l'ordre de la pathologie
auquel l'enrichissement personnel en
faveur des actionnaires et grands
gérants de hedge fund auquel donne accès
l'exercice de ce métier je pense qu'on
l'a on a une illustration de la capacité
de de certains acteurs de la finance à
être prédateur sur l'ensemble des
circuits financiers
qui qui me paraît être
de l'ordre de
maladies de notre système financier et
mon élan personnel pour essayer de
porter le fer
dans cette pathologie
donc serait d'attaquer la chose
différemment je pense que le petit coup
de ciseau sur le ms non non non je pense
qu'un des points névralgiques mais bien
identifiés et qui fait l'objet de
nombreuses tentatives est vraiment celui
des paradis fiscaux je pense que c'est
paradis fiscaux sont l'exemple même de
la gangrène qui est au coeur de notre
système financier au coeur d'un système
capitaliste qui n'est pas uniquement à
l'oeuvre d'ailleurs dans le système
financier puisque gangrène une cavalerie
mois j'assimile rsa de la gangrène à des
cellules cancéreuses
alors après évidemment des mécanismes de
cavalerie peuvent s'organiser autour de
sa donné ni comment de déni non je crois
pas de déni parce que je pense que tout
le monde a les yeux parfaitement ouvert
sur ces réalités là de plus les gens
sont informés de ce qui se passe ils
comprennent ce qui se passe écoutez je
crois que oui vous avez il ya une
lecture récente
je crois que c'est oxfam qui vient de
publier ce sens sa nouvelle édition de
son rapport sur la transparence j'avais
des ong
très très active qu'elle vous avez
notamment 36 46 et puis en france vous
avez une ong dont le nom mais pas
présent à l'esprit là mais aussi qui
oeuvrent avec
beaucoup de
je dirais de persévérance sur ces
questions là vous avez aussi les grands
organismes internationaux qui sont
saisis de cette question des paradis
fiscaux à commencer par l' ocde mais les
progrès sont sont extrêmement lents et
c'est à dessein que les progrès sont
lents
côté le doute est permis le doute est
permis mais il me semble que
je pense qu'une volonté politique un peu
plus chevillée au corps un peu plus
chevillée à l'âme d'ailleurs surtout est
ce que vous entendez par am et bien là
on refait le lien avec cette dimension
transcendante de saison vous savez je ne
crois pas que steiner soit propriétaire
en quoi que ce soit de la transcendance
et de la démarche spirituelle elles
l'ont précédée de beaucoup ça n'a été
qu'un qu'un acteur parmi des milliers
d'autres et certainement pas le plus
important sur ces terrains là mais sur
la la question des paradis fiscaux
quand on voit dans le rapport d'oxfam
que des pays comme la belgique comme le
luxembourg comme l'irlande sont
assimilés à des paradis fiscaux
et que notamment pour parler de la
belgique et du luxembourg que là nous
avons deux pays fondateurs de la
communauté économique européenne on se
dit que le ver est dans le fruit et que
c'est bien par là qu'ils feraient
commencé à l'attaquer
et s'il y avait une initiative politique
que j'appellerais de mes voeux c'est moi
je me rangerai volontiers vers ceux qui
appellent à une initiative franco
allemande pour
relancer
l'europe sur d'autres bases et en
particulier
tout ce qui peut être lié à
l'harmonisation fiscale européenne
je pense que nos les deux grands pays
qui sont au coeur de l'europe là
auraient les moyens et une
responsabilité
déterminante j'ai cité la belgique c'est
pas du wishful thinking ce moment c'est
pas du wishful si un peu un peu mais si
vous voulez le oui school wishful
thinking c'est mon mauvais anglais
ça ça fait partie aussi de la démarche
volontaire initial
les grandes idées partent
aussi peuvent aussi partir de wishful
thinking ce n'est pas interdit de
l'espérer bon mais vraiment au niveau de
la nef
mais écoutez nous on a notre petite dose
petite échelle on essaye de de
personnifier une autre façon de faire et
on d'un positionnement on va être plus
actifs en tentant de démontrer par
l'acte que de construire de savantes
penser bon alors imaginez vous j'ai cent
mille euros je veux changer de banque
oui
alors très content de la mienne pour
l'instant et peut-être pas très éthique
sur certains points est ce qu'on peut
faire ouvrir un compte pour les
particuliers chez vous non pourquoi
parce que nous n'avons pas l'agrément
pour le faire pourquoi et bien c'est une
question qu'il faudrait poser à
l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution c'est-à-dire le bras armé de
la banque de france pour réguler le
système le secteur bancaire nous avons
demandé en 2014 une extension d'agrément
nous avons obtenu le droit d'ouvrir des
comptes de professionnels et
d'entreprises nous avons obtenu le droit
d'ouvrir des comptes sur livrets pour
les particuliers de livres vu délivrer b
mais nous n'avons pas obtenu le droit
d'ouvrir des comptes bancaires
l'autorité de contrôle nous a estimé
insuffisamment près
d'un point de vue opérationnel et
technique
sincèrement elle a pas forcément tort et
donc ça reste tournon en ligne de mire
mais pour l'instant il nous faut d'abord
digérer l'étape d'extension que nous
sommes en train
de mettre en oeuvre donc si vous avez
100 mille euros vous pouvez les déposer
chez nous soit sur un livret rémunéré à
0,10 pour cent c'est vraiment de
l'inflation c'est-à-dire bien moins que
l'inflation votre pognon pognon chez
vous ça dépend quel est le sens que vous
donner au mot servir donc effectivement
pour vos finances personnelles ça sert à
rien je suis assez d'accord qu'est ce
qui pourrait me donner envie d'écouter
c'est quoi comment je peux le voir à ce
que tous les mois j'ai un petit bilan de
ce qui se passe chez vous histoire de me
motiver à perdre du fric essaye de
donner un peu de sens à l'argent qui
nous est confiée donc ce qui pourrait
vous donner envie c'est c'est l'idée que
cet argent bien nous en faisant des
petites choses qui peuvent être
peut-être ce côté avec résoudre
personnes qui ont envie de changer le
monde non ou la finance d'abord c'est
une c'est une façon d'y contribuer
le garantis sur tout ça c'est bien vous
n'avez aucune garantie particulière
ainsi la nef fait faillite et bien
vous serez logés comme n'importe quel
autre client bancaire la lame sauce avec
la fameuse garantie des dépôts à
laquelle vous sembliez attaché du prix
tout à l'heure
c'est pas qu'on semblait attaché du prix
mais quand on voit la volatilité des
marchés
comment les marchés sont un petit peu
instrumentalisé comme dans l'ex union
soviétique parce que y'a pu vraiment
pris pas d'accord avec moi du prix sur
les marchés financiers sont pas
administrés
écoutez ça dépend de quels marchés
financiers on parle ce qui est
extrêmement administrés c'est le marché
des taux courts ça c'est clair la banque
centrale européenne à travers ses taux
de référence à la mainmise entièrement
sur les taux courts
pour le reste quand on voit la
volatilité sur les taux longs quand on
voit la volatilité sur les taux actions
même si la volatilité en ce moment est
plutôt le vin assez faible vix le vix il
a combien aujourd'hui 1 comment vix est
à combien aujourd'hui aucune idée
ça fait pas partie des indicateurs qui
sent dans mon radar quels sont les
indicateurs dans votre adore et bien
donc le taux de l'euribor 3 mois le taux
de vous pencher des manipulations sur le
ruban
bien là j'en pense tout le mal possible
pouvais me résumer un petit peu eh bien
ce sont des
nous résumer pardon et bien si vous
voulez l'euribor 3 mois c'est donc le
taux auquel les banques s'échangent
l'argent en euros il y tout les toutes
les banques européennes voire mondiales
interviennent sur ce marché de l'euro
pour se prêter sans emprunter de
l'argent au jour le jour pour ce faire
et vient le long des dires des employés
qu'on appelle les traders qui sont qui
sont dédiés à ce job là est donc un
certain nombre de traders
se sont entendues
entre banques pour
manipuler les cours pour transmettre
aux
organes de compensation
publiant les les indices des taux moyens
traités par jour s'arrangeant pour leur
communiquer des fausses informations et
donc en tirant des profits
probablement
très équitablement partagés entre leur
profit personnel et le profit de leurs
institutions pour faire simple en gros
ils sont gavés avec l'aval de leur
hiérarchie c'est ça disons que certaines
hiérarchies était probablement au
courant mais je ne veux pas faire de
procès plus que ça il est possible que
certaines hiérarchies n'ait pas été au
courant je n'en sais rien mais ce sont
des jeunes des déviations qui ont fait
l'objet de lourdes sanctions qu'est ce
que vous appelez lourde parce que c'est
intéressant et bien écoutez un certain
nombre de banques ont eu des sanctions
se chiffrant en centaines de millions ou
en milliards
et puis quelle quelle banque a pris
quelques milliards qui coûte et là vous
me les les bandes qui ont été
sanctionnés sur ce marché je à ma
connaissance une sanction était à la
hauteur des profits réalisés je n'en
sais rien en tout cas une bonne partie
des grandes banques internationales a
été sanctionné sur les manipulations du
marché l'euribor donc revenons au départ
vous nous parliez de l'euribor
oui comme étant à des taux que je
suivais de près voilà oui j'en suis
ville et manipulé vous l'avez donc ôter
aux aucune idée
pour savoir s'il est encore manipuler
j'ose espérer que les instances
professionnelles
qui ont été mandatés pour cela on fait
en sorte de supprimer les déviations
antérieur je n'en ai aucune aucune idée
aucune garantie les outre les autres
indices que vous surveillez et bien le
taux de
de l'obligation française à 10 ans
et puis combien aujourd'hui
écoutés selon les jours elle aux
alentours de 1%
avec des
des variations quotidiennes qui peuvent
être significatives c'est pour ça que je
réagissais un peu quand vous disiez que
les marchés étaient complètement
administrés administrés
non on peut encore rassurez vous il ya
encore de beaux jours pour les
spéculations et sur un instrument aussi
aussi standard si je puis dire que
l'obligation française à 10 ans
vous avez des des variations
quotidiennes qui laisse encore de belles
jours aux spéculations
vous êtes plutôt plutôt de shawn cool
non je ne suis absolument pas à
intervenants sur le marché des options
le vt
écoutez
il m'est arrivé effectivement dans le
cadre d'opérations de couverture lorsque
j'étais directeur financier dans la
bande team employées à l'époque de
traiter des opérations d'options vous
qu'ouvrier contre le court bien nous
avions des
déplacements à taux variable donc nous
cherchons à couvrir le risque si vous
étiez exposé sur coup sûr le suisse sur
le court non c'était
nous étions des intervenants
franco-français donc c'était là je vous
parle de la fin des années 80
donc c'était ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque lou franche et pas si vous en
souvenez vous êtes jeunes dont vous
peut-être que
rembourser ça va coûter c'était le franc
tout court
dans la fin de ces années 80 c'était le
franc tout court et les fronts le
nouveau front voilà mes nouveaux
français bien avant on and on n'a plus
le terme nouveau franc ça doit dater des
années 60 cm vous êtes tenir en 1955 oui
donc les j'ai connu la période oman a
parlé de monsieur pinet
2007 pour le retour au franc non non
assurément non vous êtes pour l'euro je
ne suis ni pour l'euro ni pour le franc
je vais jouer ouvert pour le business
responsable non c'est parce que j'avais
vous dire même si oui je suis pour le
business responsable mais surtout par
rapport à ça si vous voulez
que ce soit mon modeste niveau personnel
au niveau de la nef nous ne sommes pas
des des praticiens d'une d'une chapelle
en tant que tel pour ou contre l'euro
c'est pas notre sujet principal la
création monétaire ça vous parle je vais
vous en parler là mais je veux juste
finir la mama réaction sur cette
question deux pour ou contre euro nous
nous sommes
intrinsèquement fondamentalement
contre
contre l'élévation de chapelle de
frontière de deux murs nous nous sommes
pour ce qui rapproche les hommes nous
essayons d'être cohérent avec notre
démarche fraternelle et
lorsque nous nous voyons des frontières
qui s'élève entre les hommes quel que
soit l'endroit où elles s'élèvent je
parle pas uniquement des frontières
territoriales et diplomatique ça nous
inquiète nous nous sommes pour une
circulation la plus libre possible mais
évidemment une circulation encadrée par
des règles qui permettent à cette
circulation d'être responsable nous
avions il ya peu de temps un projet
européen
mais la fin des années 2000 on avait
formulé avec une consoeur italienne qui
s'appelle la banque la banque attica
qui est vraiment l'ordre
typiquement dans la même démarche que
nous sont beaucoup plus gros que nous en
italie ne sont plus anciens que nous et
et ils essayent
là où ils sont de vrais dans la même
direction nous avions formulées et il y
avait un troisième larron dans
l'histoire c'était un partenaire
espagnol beaucoup plus petit du nom de
fiare et nous avions formulé un projet
de fusion transfrontalière
espagne france italie
donc ce projet a échoué
quand les économies pourri quoi
oui mais des gens pas pourri du tout
vous savez ce qui nous importe c'est
surtout les gens qui gravitent dans ces
économies économies pourri je ne sais
pas trop ce que ça veut dire je ne
connais que dès que des gens pourris ou
des gens non pour y est c'est eux qui
font ou non les économies pourri
toujours est il que ce projet européen a
échoué ne nous le regrettons beaucoup
probablement les temps ne sont pas
encore mûrs pour
organisée de façon fluide des des
fusions transfrontalières que ce soit
dans l'économie responsable
ou dans l'économie et y confins quel que
soit le nom que nous donnions maintenant
oui nous sommes effectivement pour une
économie
responsable bien sûr même si le monde
responsable c'est un mois beaucoup
d'entreprises et pense être tout
l'argent dette la création monétaire qui
souhaitait la création monétaire écoutez
c'est une question
qui ne peut pas laisser indifférent à
benquet puisque le banquier c'est celle
artisans de saison je pense que nous
sommes au point avec un banquier si si
si si mais si mais si umih n'ayez pas
c'est si cette image vous savez
chez les banques et vous trouvez donc
bien les grossistes des grossistes que
que dès que des ouvriers en passant par
des artisans voûte avait trente six
mille façons d'organiser votre rapport à
l'argent du du du pire au meilleur ne
l'oublié pas toujours est il que la
création monétaire
nous nous en sommes des modestes aux
opérateurs à à l'échelle qui est la
nôtre lorsque nous réalisons un crédit
à partir de rien vous alors à partir de
rien je pense que c'est une vision qui
est un peu rapide
et bien il faut juste avoir en tête
comment fonctionne un bilan de banques
n'est pas parler de kingston va vous
dire sur ce genre et de hayek ipad en
excuser modef occulter non là très
sincèrement je suis incapable de vous
parler de la théorie de hayek pourquoi
parce que je lis your ride tunisiens
font non je ne suis pas keynésien moi je
suis je suis pas trop théoricien
économique un jeu je suis j'aime bien
aller de du particulier au général
j'aime bien théorisé à mes heures mais
plutôt à partir de
demain réalités
professionnelles observées donc c'est
plutôt l'artisan qui devient philosophe
autour du du verre de vin auquel je
faisais référence tout à l'heure
cros crédit alors oui mais attendez la
création monétaire l'instant c'est un
point c'est vite c'est pour ça que oui
mais écoutez
vous avez a évoqué la création monétaire
est un petit peu de red bull un petit
peu de red bull écoutez pourquoi pas non
plus c'est dommage parce que ça ne fait
que ces prêts d'habitude ou mais la
pièce celui de greg zanon mais ça
m'aurait peut-être fait accélérer 1
toujours est il que la création
monétaire il faut bien avoir en tête
comme en effet un bilan de banques si
vous avez du mal à vous endormir le soir
n'hésitez pas à regarder habile est un
bide en banque ça vous aidera mais un
bilan de banques qui a une partie passif
une partie actifs et donc la partie
crédit elle est à l'actif mais cet actif
eh bien il est financé par le passif et
le passif c'est tout simplement les
dépôts des clients donc nous aujourd'hui
nous prétendons que nous ne faisons de
création monétaire qu'est la hauteur
permise par les clients par les dépôts
qu'il nous confie c'est notre façon
devrait en création monétaire évidemment
pour une banque qui se refinancent
entièrement sur les marchés le propos
est un peu plus nuancé mais voilà nous
en tout cas la conception que nous avons
de la création monétaire là la relier
entièrement à l'épargné qui nous est
confié pour vraiment
faire en sorte que mais là je commence à
me garer sur le plan corps de la finance
la pop art non c'est que l'argent relie
les hommes c'est le slogan de la nef
large aujourd'hui à 10h au moins une
fois ça
oui alors je vous disais voilà keynes
hayek hayek non layec ne sais quoi votre
votre façon pour comment formuler ça les
gars cette chose
votre prisme de lecture globale sur ce
qui ce qui est en train de se passer
beaucoup il ya une perte de sens dans le
financement de l'économie c'est ça vous
m'arrêtez si je me trompe bien coûter
non je dirais pas ça qu'est ce que vous
faisiez alors bien je dirais que oui la
perte de sens dans l'économie oui mais
je dirais que
on est sur une pente qui est pas
forcément incliné dans le sens qu'on
imagine et
l'observation que je peux faire
donc nos rides et bien du métier que
j'exerce c'est que
la pente elle est plutôt orienté dans le
sens de la remontée je pense que à
l'échelle du système bancaire français
pour parler de ce que je connais le
mieux on est dans une pente
on est en train de remonter la pente et
que le système bancaire français et est
en train progressivement avec bien sûr
peut-être
à redire ici ou là mais le système
bancaire français et est en train de
remonter cette pente de mise au service
de l'économie
aujourd'hui oui
vous êtes persuadé
c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'observe il faut avoir il
faut avoir à l'esprit qu'aujourd'hui
plus des trois quarts du marché de l'art
ce qu'on appelle la banque de détail en
france est détenue par des banques
coopératives
et des banques comme la société générale
ou bnp p ne détiennent que des parts de
marché minoritaire sur sur le monde de
la banque de détail en france les grands
acteurs ces groupes cas d'école crédit
mutuel bon c'est donc cic crédit mutuel
crédit mutuel cic crédit lyonnais la
banque pasche c'est ça cic banque page
crédit mutuel dans ce pot ça
coûté
probablement hélas la banque pasche est
une jeune fille a dû cesser je leur
décès comment la banque tosh non je
connais pas plus que ça non toujours est
il que
ces grandes banques on me semble-t-il
tiré des premières conclusions de la
crise financière de 2008 et j'observe à
l'intérieur de ces grandes maisons une
volonté réelle de remettre de l'ordre
dans les boutiques frédéric coup d'oeil
plus du tout de paradis fiscaux société
générale si je parlais des grandes
banques mutualistes et coopératives
je serai effectivement moins affirmatif
sur ce qui se passe sur les autres
banques mais je parle du du monde des
bandes coopératif l'intérieur de banque
coopérative à l'intérieur duquel nous
évoluerons et on peut observer en
particulier un
phénomène de reterritorialisation avec
une véritable volonté de toutes les
banques coopératives de relier l'épargné
collectée avec
l'activité économique de leur territoire
on vient de loin
et donc on ne gomme pas les déviances du
passé d'un trait de plume mais moi il me
semble observer de la place où je suis
kylie a une
une dynamique est plutôt encourageante
espérons le
microcrédit ont fait du microcrédit à la
nef alors on fait du microcrédit
professionnel à notre crédit moyen à la
nef ses cent mille euros notre médiane
c'est quarante mille euros et on a une
proportion substantielle de nos crédits
qui est inférieur à 25 mille euros donc
c'est ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de
microcrédit alors il faut s'entendre sur
ce qui est financé à travers ces crédits
la donc nous nous finançons des des
projets de création d'entreprise
qu'est-ce qu'on soit les secteurs ça
peut être des projets dans le monde
agricole ça peut être des projets dans
le domaine de la distribution dans le
domaine de la transformation ça peut
être des projets culturels mais nous
sommes assez présent à kehl tout
écouter sur un microcrédit nous nous
allons intervenir à des taux entre 3 et
4%
j'ai pas bien compris la
photo vous ces 3 4% sur un microcrédit
ça va être un ordre de grandeur oui
c'est parce que c'est risqué le
microcrédit chez vous
alors d'une part c'est risqué et et
d'autre part il ya juste un détail qu'on
oublie c'est que les heures de travail
des personnes qui instruisent ces
micro-crédits il faut les rémunérer
aujourd'hui notre activité de
microcrédit est lourdement déficitaire
même avec les taupes nous pratiquons
c'est une des difficultés de la nef et
est donc aujourd'hui je peux affirmer
même si je suis pas juge et partie dans
ce que je vais vous dire que le déficit
de la nef est davantage dû à à sa
problématique
d'équilibrage de son activité de
microcrédit que de rémunération de son
dirigeant
vous devancez ma question bon on arrive
à la fin de notre interview hélas
on a une question qui est récurrente
c'est laisser une bouteille à la mer
pour les jeunes générations non mais sur
internet
donner un conseil aux jeunes générations
maintenant tout de suite sur le sujet
que vous voulez
entreprenez entreprenez prenez votre
destin en main
comptez pas sur je ne sais quels
appuis systémique ne comptez pas sur je
ne sais quel miracle politique nous
sommes dans un monde qui est je parle
avec le recul d'un vieil homme qui est
de mon point de vue a ouvert comme
jamais le champ des possibles pour
quelqu'un qui a l'esprit de vie et
d'entreprises chevillée au corps vous et
la nef sera prête à vous encourager dans
ce sens parce que vous avez une question
à nous poser
bien écouter
je ne sais pas dites moi comment vous
avez vécu cette heure ça a été un bon
moment pour vous
je demande à mes collègues parce que en
fait on plug nos cerveaux ont fait comme
une seule entité ça a été ça a été c'est
bon pas d'autres questions
non
bon c'est un peu fait chier quoi
bon non je blague hein il ya toujours un
fond de vérité dans ce qu'on vient et
on était très contents de vous recevoir
on était très contents
d'aborder tout de suite le sujet de
steiner de prime abord parce que c'est
dans notre communauté un poids
d'adhérence qui en a stressé
chez nous on écoute tout le monde y
compris des papiers assassin sur la nef
merci d'avoir essayé d'avoir la plus
grande franchise à votre égard
et puis voilà merci merci à vous
[Musique]